as Chris Elliot once said on get a life
he got the uh the attention span of a
circus
monkey we were you into that show oh my
gosh made me so happy in fact my first
big job was in Cabin Boy oh that's right
go was working with Chris Elliot which
was why I bring that up yes a contest
Adam yeah an Adam res ad oh my gosh to
me their work is like the Rosetta Stone
of modern comedy I just I love
everything about and they're delightful
people well it was wonderfully formative
for me too in that you were wonderful in
that movie I mean what a great job
you're diding that yeah but it was
wonderful for me in the sense that I my
first big thing because I did I I was in
like I had a bit part in another like in
a what we used to call Cable movies okay
um which was do you mind taking me
through this or is this irritating
because I would love to know how you
auditioned and and I would love the
story of how you cuz that was a good
role especially for a big role and it it
it was uh I mean at at that time they
were recognized as just the Geniuses of
Comedy it was an auspicious thing yes
and you know and it had it had Tim
Burton behind it Tim Burton and um
Denise denovi was his producer and she
was there on set Tim Burton like would
pop in every now and then right I had
been in LA and I talked about this on
the show I did a a a live show called
the real life Brady Bunch that started
in Chicago went to New York was in in LA
and that was winding down and because of
the popularity of that show I had gotten
an agent in New York based on being
Mike Brady they had an
affiliation with an agency out here a
little agen like they called it a
boutique agency A Little Agency actually
just down the street from here literally
two blocks down the street Boutique
meant that you paid for all post post
office deliveries and right yeah the
clients covered well I found out the
thing the real glue that bonded them all
together was alcoholism oh my God you
mean like America
like but um when I start when I first
came to LA and I had these I you know I
came here with an agent which was
already so yeah lucky and they sent me
out on everything and I was aware like
I'm auditioning for all different kinds
of things and and I got a job I got like
a little bit part and again it was like
a really it was a movie called the uh
incredibly the allegedly true Adventures
of the Texas cheerleading murdering Mom
okay remember how there was like a there
cheerlead there another version of that
film two of those this was the satirical
one directed by Michael Richie wow who
did the movie smile who's kind of in the
Alman kind of event who was fantastic
and I went in and read for him and I was
part I was a sheriff's deputy in a
montage of Bo Bridges going to to the
sheriff and saying my ex- sister-in-law
wants me to murder someone and they just
kind of brushed him off so there was
this Montage of people taking a
statement and I came in and he went oh
one of the deputies is younger yeah I
like this and then I read for him and he
was like he's like all right great you
got the part amazing and I again heard
that what the and even I knew and I
had read for other things you like I
remember reading for H Golden Palace
which was The Golden Girls after I think
B Arthur said enough and left the other
Golden Girls aftermash ran yeah like ran
a restaurant or something it was like
for a part of an ethnic Chef you know
like I you know you know you look at me
and you think that guy is from somewhere
warm right that's what ethnic
men but I got and I got the part in that
in that movie and then the next thing
was Cabin Boy and and you know playing
the damaged man child was right at my
alley and I I read for it once and who'
you read for you a casting director or
casting director yeah for the first time
and you put me on tape and and then um
great that's what they always say great
thank you that was great they they had
me read again and uh while I was still
here and then it was at the end of my
Brady Bunch tenure okay and and I went
back to Chicago I drove my Toyota pickup
truck back to Chicago was at my mother's
house living in my mother's days it's a
couple of days yeah I mean you know you
however long you want to make it but
they want they said we we want you to
come back and audition again and I was
broke my my mom was
broke luckily my uncle had backed his
delivery truck into my mother's car no
way she took the insurance money from
that bought me a the cheapest Southwest
ticket that we could get which had like
four stops on the way to La yeah came
back to LA stayed with a friend in
Venice slept on her couch borrowed Jane
Lynch's car because Jane Lynch was had
was was back inico left her car there so
I borrowed her car got a bunch of
traffic tickets which I you know took me
I you know she got a call about and she
still giv me TR you know it's
now joking but she was
pissed
$600 you it wasn't that much but it was
like but I mean I didn't have money and
I just and you know and it's like I
wasn't I don't you know I don't get
parking tickets now hardly ever I don't
know what the the problem was
hardly ever back then you had to be so
careful yeah but because if you go to
parking ticket all your profit was G
yeah yeah yeah so I came back and I read
again uhuh once again so that that was
the third time and this was for Adam wow
and then they had me read yet again I
stay they're like stick around we know
what's going to H you know so I was like
at my friend's house and I I had gone
and bought I bought a foil tray and made
a big tray of lasagna and then I ate
lasagna for every meal that's awesome uh
and and then after that and I mean
because the money was Runing out I
bought I bought baloney bread and cheese
and then it was baloney sandwiches cuz I
was there for like a week yeah and I
would buy a giant tub of peanut butter
from a a Costco or or I forget what the
name of the other place in La used to be
where where you could get huge things of
peanut butter yeah yeah Smart and Final
Smart and Final yeah smart neither smart
but final yes uh but yeah that's what I
would do but okay so so you get the we
and you're driving everybody who lives
in La crazy because there's this guy who
comes out and is and I have nothing to
do I can't afford to do anything so they
I went back right at the beginning of it
and then they had me come back one more
time like after 4 days of sitting around
just waiting for just that yes and they
they when I went back to read uh at the
casting agency before I went in I asked
to use the restroom and the key fob you
know the don't walk away with our key
key fob was a big long back scratcher a
plastic back scratcher like with a hand
yeah and written down the the shaft of
the uh back scratcher was I'm itching to
read for you and then an actor's name
their phone number and their agent oh my
word so somebody had gone out and made
swag thinking that these back scratchers
are pretty clever and that will get me
an acting job my word and I just was I
just remember like setting it on top of
the Ural and just noticing it as I'm
peeing and just feeling like my guts
dropping out like like just and again
like the Des the depr you know you know
how like when when you're already like
sad most of the time and then you see
something sad and it's just and that to
me that was the the feeling was always
like I felt like the insides of my
abdomen just melted and pulled down at
the bottom like down in my pelvis and
then I'm just like oh what am I
just like what am I doing with all of
this what an image I went in and read
again yeah later that day they called
and they said said stick around and I
actually was like I was like I can't
hoop I got to go home I got to I said
I've read for you four time and I I said
I read four times I think you know yeah
and uh and then I went home and then I
got the job and uh remember how you
found out drove back drove back in my
pickup truck uh back just a call just a
phone call yeah from my agent and they
were were they excited when they called
oh my God they were they were thrilled
and were you excited oh my agent my
agent said to me when he called me he
was like I cried when they told me I
cried and then I was in his office about
a month later and he was making a call
to someone telling him they got a job
and he went I cried oh no when I got the
news I cried that's how much it needs
and I was like my gosh these phonies
these phonies oh my word and we
buy every word of it and and what was
even better was this agent that like I
said had sent me out on all kinds of
things yeah now I was just idiots that's
all I ever saw was like barely like IQ
of seven dumb dumb idiots and that's all
they ever sent me out on from that point
wow yeah
wow